the House passed a bill by a four vote
margin this week to repeal and replace
Obamacare but the bills future is not
certain as Senate Republicans are
planning to write their own version
White House spokeswoman Sarah Sanders
said the president will not hurry the
Senate a mace is a process we haven't
put a timeline or a deadline we want to
get it right not get it fast and that's
the that's the focus a major issue in
the Senate version is a possible change
to Medicaid starting in 2020 it would
put caps on Medicaid funding for more
we're joined from Washington by Sarah
Kliff senior editor for box
she's been closely following the debate
over health care Sarah good morning good
morning 13 Republican senators are
working to craft the new bill in the
Senate what do we expect from them Sarah
so we expect them to issue a more
moderate bill there are a number of
Republicans who are really concerned
about those medicaid cuts you mentioned
both the caps on spending also it would
end Obamacare's Medicaid expansion which
covers about 12 millions Americans right
now so they're concerned about that they
are also concerned about the subsidies
in the individual market one of the
things Obamacare did was give
middle-income and low-income families
some help buying private insurance and
those would be scaled down under the
house plan so I think there's also some
concern in the Senate about those
subsidies as well
Sarah we know that you spoke with
relevant Senator Bill Cassidy he was
concerned about premium increases in the
House bill what can you tell us about
that right so you could see a lot of
Americans particularly older Americans
in the individual market facing some
really steep increases under this bill
the report from the Congressional Budget
Office on the earlier draft of this bill
found that a low-income American who's
64 could see their premiums go up 750
percent those are people who often vote
Demming
so there's a political concern and a
policy concern that you could see some
people pretty frustrated with some big
premium increases like that Sarah you
wrote a piece breaking down the winners
and losers from this house vote and you
put President Trump down as both a
winner and a loser why is that so I
think he's a winner because
he got something done it's been a
administration so far that has not had a
lot of legislative wins that has really
struggled to get off the ground so they
move this through the house when a lot
of us were expecting it might not make
it that being said you know a one of the
things President Trump has done
repeatedly is promised that this bill
will cover everyone it'll protect people
with pre-existing conditions and there
are a lot of ways that the promises he
has made just aren't true they are not
the bill that the House passed doesn't
live up to his promises and if it
becomes law he's going to have to
confront that at some point when people
realize you know they don't have
coverage or that their premiums did go
up under this plan so I think it's fair
to say he's both the winner and the
loser he moved something forward but
it's not the bill that he has been
describing and a lot of the interviews
he has done Sarah there's unusual unity
between medical groups doctors groups
patient groups and insurers in
opposition to what the House passed we
haven't gotten a score from the
Congressional Budget Office yet but it
is your expectation that it will be more
politically questionable or difficult
for lawmakers to stand behind than the
previous score that's a great question
and so we're expecting to score from CBO
maybe this week or next week and it's
not totally clear what it's going to
look like our best guess is it'll
probably be in the ballpark of the last
score which found that 24 million
Americans would lose insurance coverage
and we're going to see how legislators
deal with this one of the differences
this time is in the first CBO score that
came out before the vote and the vote
never happened in part because that
score was so toxic when it found that
millions of Americans would lose health
insurance coverage now House Republicans
have already taken that vote they didn't
know how many people it covers how much
it costs but they're going to have to
stand by that vote and defend it when we
get these numbers on the bill in the
near future sir if this Republican
health care plan becomes law how do you
think it might affect the millions of
Americans who are on private employer
based health plans so most of us won't
feel a change there are about 160
million Americans who get health
insurance at work and this bill doesn't
do a lot to change that the
is one possible way they could change
the Wall Street Journal reported a story
earlier this week finding a loophole in
the Republican bill that would allow
insurance companies to bring back
lifetime limits so essentially to cap
insurance benefits it usually one or two
million dollars this is something a lot
of employer plans did before the
Affordable Care Act which outlawed this
practice it doesn't affect most of us
but it does affect people who have
especially high health care bills or
there are a number of cases of babies
born premature who need a lot of care in
the NICU who would get affected by
lifetime limit so that's the one way it
seems to intersect with employer
sponsored insurance but generally people
get coverage at work should not expect
much change Sarah Kliff in Washington
this morning thank you Sarah
thank you